number one if you indeed across America
drugs and the violent crime they spawn
but there's no way of our sealing off
our borders so the drugs won't come in
Mexico is a mess violence is everywhere
with powerful cartels taking on the
police and the government drug gangs
make billions with much of that coming
from smuggling narcotics and people
across the United States border it
wasn't always this way so how did the
narcos take control of Mexico as Mexico
itself responsible though well actually
know the 60s and 70s Mexico had good
relations with the state and a very
successful Employment Group the term
most commonly used is brass barrel they
could work as relatively well-paid
domestic staff and agricultural
employees for specific periods of time
sending their money home and then
ultimately going home it was well agreed
or well understood they did the jobs
nobody in the USA wanted to do and then
for political reasons it was stopped the
employees and more importantly the
employer's still wanted the cross-border
were to continue but it was illegal so
began the illegal movement of people
across this huge border crime gangs took
over from immigration stop the movement
of people was the start of the movement
of anything
[Music]
the biggest consumer of legal and
illegal drugs in the world is the United
States of America the big suppliers of
heroin cocaine and marijuana were
countries in Central and South America
the most prolific of which was Colombia
Colombian drug cartels were the
benchmark of badness and ability the
United States had been involved in
constant Cold War battles with Russia in
South America
quite often supported or fought the
regime's who were basically drug cartels
there was no long-term planning based on
what was good or bad for the world it
was all about fighting the Communists in
this crazy environment swinging in cash
the gangs made a fortune and had the
room to develop sophisticated and well
organized mass movement infrastructure
gangs in Mexico were created and
employed by the ruthless and hugely
powerful South American cartels the
Mexicans were nothing more than postman
they delivered the product the point is
Mexico was always the key it was the
gateway number one issue indeed across
America is drugs and the violent crime
they spark realizing that it was all
getting out of control and coinciding
with the end of the Cold War the United
States woke up to the fact it had a
massive domestic drug problem and it had
a basically a sister to create it so
they decided to take the war to the
South American cartels this is a hefty
price Colombia will pay for failing to
cooperate fully in the war on drugs they
were successful at busting them up the
problem was that demand in the United
States had not diminished in fact it had
growth if we can't decrease the demand
but there's no way of our sealing off
our borders so the drugs won't come in
the cartels in South America had been
weakened but there was still a loss of
product being produced all it was needed
was the continuation of delivery and
that was when the Mexican gangs realized
they were in the driving seat so now we
have the Mexican organizations becoming
very significant wholesalers of cocaine
in their own right
they've been employed and were
threatened by South American cartels and
then they said no you want to sell this
we ain't taking ten percent we're taking
sixty and then 80 and then you know what
my friend they would say we'll produce
package and move everything South
American cartels were finished as a
power
the Mexican narcos use their systems and
the planning of the original Big
Brothers but refined it they still are
postman now they're also the entire
Postal Service and the entire production
firm the roots they move the drugs
through were theirs they also realize
they could use their roots and
infrastructure for moving anything in
recent years it has become people from
all over the world they control the lot
the tentacles of the cartels are
absolutely everywhere if you visit
Mexico you're in some way or other
paying the cartels it is utterly ingrate
and so far nobody has thought of a way
to stop it well I have they just end up
dead